Hey so I guess I should probably just
click to introduce myself say like most
of us here I think
was interfaith science one way or
another so I actually started off as a
design engineer and even though I worked
as a data scientist now I kind of find
it hard to let go of what I used to do a
little bit so some of these these
examples I'm going to go through is kind
of my attempt to sort of hold on to my
past but also I think data science has a
lot of application in design both
engineering design but also product
design so hopefully I can kind of
illustrate that to you guys today so the
the core of this talk really is it kind
of centered around these three these
three examples on the left this is you
might not be able to make out what this
really is but this is actually like a
shrouding which goes around a propeller
on a drone so we added particular use
case where apply and wanted to use an
off-the-shelf drone for just to do some
structural surveying however they had
quite a lot of constraints from health
and safety and they wanted to be able to
kind of shroud the propeller so the
design problem here is how can you
introduce this new component into the
drone and not kind of sacrifice the
performance so this is like kind of like
an engineered design that is trying to
like optimize to make sure that it
doesn't impact the performance with the
drone itself in the middle at vanpool
that's actually a skateboard shoe
concept and this was - the goal of this
project was to optimize a shoe to
satisfy a particular skating style so
I'll talk about this one in a bit more
detail but that's also an optimization
problem and a third one is a render from
a smoke animation so in this case the
optimization problem is to come up with
something that looks aesthetically
pleasing so these three all have a few
things in common but they're very very
different I guess the first thing is
that they are all optimization problems
and they're actually all the result of
Bayesian optimization so that's going to
be the key theme as well as Bayesian
optimization I wanted to talk more
around Bayesian methods but I realize
there's quite a lot to talk about in 35
minutes so I've kind of restricted
Bayesian optimization they enough they
have another thing in common in a sense
that actually understand the performance
of any of these things is actually quite
a complex and expensive task so in the
sense in the ducted-fan example to
actually evaluate that and understand
the performance took four hours of
computational time for the for the shoe
to understand how the grip interacted to
the skateboard and also to sort of
better understand the cushioning and how
the skater like lights the cushioning
and how he feels about the cushioning
kind of requires again a bit of
computational simulation time but also
prototyping simulation testing and all
these things are expensive to do and
cost a lot of money in time and a third
problem well it's kind of up to you how
long you want to render an image for and
how what sort of resolution you want to
get but kind of to generate an animation
at quite a high frame rate will take a
few hours at least so I kind of really
want to just introduce the problem from
like a designer point of view but what
you'll see here is actually the Bayesian
optimization so I don't want to make any
assumptions that anyone seen Bayesian
optimization before so I'm going to
start from the beginning so this gray
curve which you might be able to see but
it doesn't really matter because you're
not supposed to be able to see it this
is like an unknown function that you're
trying to optimize over so in this case
that's less assumed this kind of models
the drag about that ducted-fan that we
looked at so what we want to do is we
want to basically come up with the
design that minimizes the drag so we
need to make some sort of decisions as
to what parameters to evaluate to get
there so on the x-axis we've got like a
design parameter so we can change this
design parameter which will change the
geometry which will then impact it
performance so what do we do like what
what what designs to be evaluate to
optimize the performance of this fan
there isn't really much data science
going on right now because there is no
data so
the best thing I can do is I've just got
this straight line going through zero
and I haven't got anything to actually
like to fit a model to or really
understand what's going on so the first
thing we need to do is go away and
actually take some measurements so this
is kind of like an initial set of
samples so I've evaluated this this
design at a few different geometries
that are given by the X variable I've
chosen five evaluations in this case you
can kind of do this randomly but it kind
of makes sense if you try and space
these out a little bit there's only five
evaluations there but this took four
hours to run and actually evaluate the
performance so that's still 20 hours
worth of work so you can start to see
how it's quite an expensive process to
actually make improvements on this
design so what do I do about making
improvements like today there's you can
see there's an area on the left-hand
side which I haven't actually evaluated
yet so do I go over there there's a
region around X equal to zero point six
which is kind of the best design I've
seen so far so I could decide to kind of
exploit that region and you know this is
the kind of decision that you need to
make as a designer what do I evaluate
next and this is where Bayesian
optimization is super helpful you tend
to use something called in that position
function and you can construct this
acquisition function in any way that you
wish but it's quite common to sort of
try and balance the idea of exploring
new areas and exploiting areas that you
already know perform pretty well so I'm
gonna make use of this acquisition
function this acquisition function is
based on this approximation of what's
really going on which is this blue line
so I just add a new point at the point
where there was this maximum kind of
expected improvement and that just took
another four hours so what do I do next
I just sequentially iterate and keep
maximizing this area of expect of
improvement and then adding and running
a new design there
so after about ten evaluations I've kind
of found this kind of minima so I've
minimized the drag of this design that's
still 40 hours worth of work so you know
even though there's a very few data
points it's still an expensive
time-consuming process to do that okay
so I kind of shown the process but I
wanted to make sure that anyone that is
completely new to Bayesian optimization
had a little bit of an understanding as
to how it's working so the next few
slides is just to sort of give a little
like introduction about what's going on
here so there's two key components to
what I just showed you the first was
this model and it's quite common to use
Gaussian processes in Beijing
optimization you do not have you don't
have to but it's quite a common thing to
use and the second thing was the
acquisition function so the first thing
to introduce is the Gaussian process and
there's lots of really sophisticated
libraries to do it and I wouldn't
necessarily encourage you to write it up
yourself but to show you that it isn't
that complicated or longer the users
numpy and that's popular to profit so
the first thing to introduce before we
talk about Gaussian processes is random
variables and the reason for talking
about this is because the Gaussian
process is just a generalization of a
random variable so hopefully if you
understand random variables the Gaussian
processes aren't too difficult at all
this is actually a multivariate random
variable
funky multivariate normal random
variable and that's characterized by a
mean and some covariance and I mean I
should say what a random variable really
is a random variable is a variable that
just doesn't take a single value but it
can take a range of values so each time
you evaluate what that variable is
you'll get a different answer the answer
you get will be based on some
characterized by some sort of
probability and this is how you can
construct it this is bivariate so
there's two variables here so you kind
of create your median standard deviation
you
covariants and a really popular way to
just visualize this is just to take
realizations and see what you come out
with and that's what this random
variable it's like I'm guessing this
isn't too dissimilar to what think
people have seen before so hopefully
everyone still with me but what you sort
of see is both X 1 and X 2 vary between
minus 4 and 4 they kind of have a
central tendency around zero but there's
also this sort of structure to it where
if if I increase X 1
I'm also likely to have a higher value
of x 2 if I just predict project all
that data onto the x-axis onto the axes
you get what is like the marginal
distribution and that's kind of not
really giving you everything any new
information really to what I just told
you but another way to visualize this is
to sort of plot them on vertical axes
and sort of join the lines between the
data points so if I just take any one of
those dots I can draw a line between you
know two vertical axes there's nothing
actually in the middle but sometimes
this helps people visualize how this
that can start to generate like the
function space rather than just a very
variable space okay so this is the
useful bit so when I make an observation
about one of these variables it actually
gives me quite a lot of information
about the other variable so if I sample
or if I observe that X 2 is equal to 1
then it actually reduces my uncertainty
about what X 1 is I now think that X 1
is likely to be great in the 0 and I'm
kind of a little bit more certain about
it and that's the conditional
conditional distribution another way to
think about it is out of all those
random samples that I had originally if
I say X 2 equals 1 I can just throw away
all the samples that don't equal x 2
equals 1 and it's just the ones that are
left basically in some way and then
that's the distribution you get and then
if you visualize that on the right-hand
side you can see I'm really certain
about X 2 and because I've made that
observation X 1 is now between -2 and 3
rather than being between minus four and
four so this concept of having an
observation and then learning a little
bit more about what's going on around
you is just the concept that you would
apply to a gaps in process and they're
pretty much characterized in a really
similar way you just have a mean or a
set of means and then you have this pay
variance function again and you can
construct it like this in this case the
mean is a function of X but it's
actually just equal to zero everywhere
and my covariance you can kind of do
what you want there are some rules you
have to kind of correlate your data
points in some way and there are a few
rules you have to follow but you can be
pretty flexible about it
I find I try you try and show you a
little bit of an example in a minute but
basically I'm just taking all my all my
X's and doing a pairwise comparison and
taking the squared difference and then
yeah doing the exponential of it and
just like before I passed this mean and
the covariance into this random number
generator a multivariate random number
generator and I can generate some
realizations the difference now is that
I'm not just taking a realization of a
single data point I'm now I'm taking a
realization of a function so a Gaussian
process as seeing a realization is a
collection of functions basically and
then you can just pull the functions out
that you please if I increase the number
of realize realizations
I have no data yet I'm just drawing
realizations from the Gaussian process
so you can start to see how this is kind
of centered at zero and then it's got
this plus minus one kind of standard
deviation going on like I said you can
kind of do what you want in this
covariance so I can add I could start
adding a bunch of hyper parameters and
this can kind of help me control what's
going on a little bit so in this case
hopefully you'll see a difference so
basically what I'm saying here is as I
move away from X whereas X moves away
from one another
y changes more rapidly so if you've got
a more rapidly moving function then you
can actually model it by including these
sort of hyper parameters there's an
other stuff you could do so rather than
assuming assuming a zero mean I could
assume a mean that does actually change
of X and that's kind of then baked in a
linear trend into my Gaussian process so
you can play around this covariance and
this mean function as much as you want
really so what happens when I have beta
well the same thing happens as well it
did with the multivariate random
variable and when I have data you kind
of create a conditional Gaussian process
and then you basically see that it
effects the information around it
another way to look at this is that of
all those realizations I've had before
I've added a data point and all the
realizations that pass through that data
point I keep and all the realizations
that don't pass through that data point
I throw away and that's kind of like the
intuition I suppose you know I can start
adding more data points and it's quite
nice properties in the sense that I'm
not modeling the mean in any way I'm
just kind of taking these realizations
and out of it I'm kind of getting a
distribution that is quite natural to
quantify uncertainty and also give you
like an average outcome of the model
that you're trying to try number TriNet
model
I should point out you don't have to be
doing realizations all the time that all
this can be done analytically it's just
to try and show some intuition about
what's going on and so what about the
acquisition function so in Bayesian
optimization you would have some data
you'd fit a Gaussian process or some
other model to it and then you would use
that more than a way to help you decide
where to evaluate next in this case I
want to make improvements on my best
design found so far and in this case
let's say we're minimizing so my best
design found so far is around four and a
half and it's equal to about minus one
so a really simple acquisition function
is to look at all the realizations that
are below minus one and divide it by my
total number of realizations so you can
see that there's no realizations over
the left-hand side that are below minus
one so I've got I've got zero here you
can see over on this right-hand side
there's a whole bunch of realizations
that go below minus one and then I can
just kind of work out the probability of
actually being better than my current
best design this is just heuristic base
so this is all like not smooth and nice
but if you're doing it properly then
this would just be all analytical and be
nice and smooth it's really important to
note like these acquisition functions
you can kind of manipulate to do what
you want like if if you don't think
you've got like this multivariate design
space and you've just got like this nice
convex problem which just has a simple
direction to find improvements then you
can just use pure exploitation so you
just kind of take the point that you
know is good so far or what your model
predicts to be better and then you just
exploit in that region
another option is pure exploration so if
you actually want to build like a
globally accurate model and then you
want to use that for lay either
visualization or sensitivity analysis
then you can actually just keep updating
your model in the region that you've got
maximum uncertainty or really large
uncertainty so basically where I haven't
already saw
you might have constraints you might
have multiple objectives you might have
noisy functions you might have
stochastic functions and all these
things can kind of be built into this
acquisition function which always kind
of helps you make improvements on your
current best designs I imagine most
people are kind of familiar with this in
the sense of high parameter tuning and
machine learning if it is the same thing
but I'm applying it to design problems
rather than machine learning problems
right let's get back to the the case
studies because that's what I really
wanted to sort of illustrate today okay
so this is that that ducted-fan that
goes around the drone propeller so like
I said when we introduced this new
component to the drone we're going to
impact the performance of the drone
we're adding weight you're gonna have to
increase the power requirements there's
a whole bunch of stuff you need to start
thinking about so you need to kind of
design this thing by carefully and the
idea is that you kind of kind of adding
this thing which should theoretically
mean that you need more thrust to keep
this drone up in the air but if you
design it carefully you can actually
generate thrust from the ducting itself
and the way you kind of do that is you
pull the air through it and if you can
get a nice region of kind of negative
pressure I guess on the front leading
edge you're kind of causing a component
of lift as well so that's what we're
really going for here but it's quite
it's quite a challenging problem in the
sense that the geometry is so subtle it
has a big impact on what the performance
of the actual ducting would do so try
and illustrate the problem a little bit
more this is like a cross section of the
ducting so imagine that duct imagine me
taking a slice through that plane the
line in the middle is kind of where the
propeller would be whizzing around and
then I've got a bunch of design
parameters so these parameters are the
ones that I need to find accommodation
of that gives me the best performance so
there's a really really obvious one so
this is basically oh I knew that was
gonna happen
I haven't quite got the knack of these
little widget things yes this played the
chord ratio basically kind of increases
the size reduces the size that's kind of
one parameter I can play with so maybe
in that first example I showed you that
just one the example maybe it was just
the size or something like that some
things are really subtle but hopefully
you can sort of see the angle of attack
so that's kind of like pulling it
inwards
some of these are more to do with the
actual air at the surface of the
geometry so some of these are quite
obvious if that kind of makes things a
bit fatter yeah anyway you get the idea
so basically I've got eight parameters
that I need to play around with to come
up with a really good design the problem
is it takes four hours each time I make
a change to one of these sliders and
rerun I've got to wait four hours to get
result so the kind of system that we put
together for this is all the
optimization engine is in - and that is
that Bayesian optimization routine that
we're talking about that kind of like
adds a few designs to EQ the 3d geometry
is crated in a in a program called
rhinoceros and this is a really nice
program because it does have a Python
API it is ironpython so it's not ideal
but as a Python developer it's really
easy to automate the geometry generation
and turning that into something which
you could then send off to an analysis
packages package so in this case what
we're interested in is that simulating
the flow the airflow over that duct
we're interested in simulating the blade
spinning and drawing the air through it
and to do that we're using a
computational fluid fluid dynamics
package called star CCM plus and this is
the bit that takes all the time this is
a bit that takes like four hours to run
and then when we get the output we can
then feed that back to the debating
optimization engine and we can then
decide what to do next so just going
around this lower loop would be what you
just normally do in a hype of parameter
tuning for example
but what we wanted to do is you know
this is an engineering design problem
there's engineers that study
aerodynamics we don't want to just let a
machine decide to do everything so
having the user in the loop having a
human being able to influence the
direction of the optimization routine is
really important so we built this little
web app which means that the user can
actually monitor what the best design
seen so far is so you know after four
hours of running you can then see and
there's like Oh has that got Bella no
let's leave it for a number four hours
see what happens if he sees something
that's really cool but he thinks oh
actually from my know my domain
knowledge about this if I just slightly
change the leading radius or the the
tail geometry a little bit I can
resubmit this back into the queue again
and what actually happens is out to then
picked up by this Gaussian process it's
then picked up by the acquisition
function and you're influencing the
optimization routine by having this
human in the loop and this is kind of
what happened
this was quite a long process so we
reran it's like a hundred twenty
iterations which was like two weeks I
think it was running for a long time so
having this web app was also quite
useful because you could actually like
check in to make sure is actually still
running and I think I remember what my
initial set of examples was but I think
after about 60 or 80 maybe that's when
it starts using this like acquisition
function that's better an improvement so
you kind of start to see it jumping
around a lot less the contour plot is
like the current best design so that's
not updating on every iteration that's
just staying as what is our best design
so if we run out of time run out of
money that's kind of what we're left
with and you'll notice that the
objective function is the combination of
the propeller Frost and also deduct rust
so you can sort of see as this
optimization routine goes up the object
as a total thrush goes up it's actually
the ducked thrust that where it we're
increasing so that's because of the
geometry of the ducting the ducting
itself
I won't leave it to the end because I
don't around of time okay so that's like
a really solid engineering example but I
said I was going to talk about product
design as well which isn't always so
engineering based so this is that that
skateboard shoe concept so we really
focused on two things here one was the
interaction with the skateboard so the
grip and the other thing was like the
cushioning of the shoe and this is
actually the final design but show you
how we got there so the idea really this
is just a concept so it's kind of like
you know as a skater I could go onto a
website I get put in my shoe size my
weight my kind of skating styles or some
people I want to like like know what the
staples are doing all the time they're
doing like really subtle tricks while
someone's doing really big tricks they
need like loads of cushioning in their
shoes and there's a whole bunch of
things they could come in they can sort
of tune it and then the optimization
problem is to go away and design them
the problem the perfect shoe so the
first thing we played around with was
the grip so this is kind of like a small
section from the out the outside of the
sole and there's a bunch of parameters
of which will manipulate the geometry so
you can kind of see that one parameter
is kind of changing it from like these
like tessellated squares to these
hexagons one parameter starts midok
manipulating it in the sense that it
kind of becomes less it protrudes less
and then it kind of makes you outside
between more you kind of get the idea so
in this case we've got five parameters
which manipulate this geometry and we
did the same thing again rhino
rhinoceros was used for this 3d geometry
there's also really cool package called
grasshopper which is what allows you to
parameterize your geometry really nicely
and then that can actually be controlled
by Python so you can kind of imagine
that geometry being manipulated by a
bunch of sliders which you just control
using Python we use a different package
for the simulation here this is hyper
works but the same concept applies so we
kind of come up with this objective
function based on these user preferences
and then we optimize and again this is
kind of like what happened so you can
sort of see the variation in the
different geometries for the grit
pattern I'm at a time saying that this
is the other problem was the soul so or
the you know how the soul is constructed
for like the cushioning so we kind of
came up with this sort of
parameterization which is kind of based
on these Voronoi tessellation z' and
what you could do is in the areas of
higher the fire load higher pressure and
so kind of on the balls of your feet and
then your heel you can kind of have a
more tessellations and you can kind of
take points away and add points and move
them all around and you can kind of
control how the load is kind of
distributed across the shoe this is
actually in the 3d volume so this is
like I don't think it over anyway you
kind of move one of these center points
of the Voronoi balloons and you kind of
change the structure of that that kind
of cushioning that's all so by basically
parameterizing this in such a way you
can like manipulate all these center
points and you can kind of get the
perfect cushioning in theory
so yeah okay so I said about product
design not quite being like engineered I
really wanted to kind of show an example
which didn't require any engineering
simulation complicated fluid dynamics
structural analysis and stuff so I kind
of wanted example which is purely based
on what I thought looked cool so how do
you optimize something that you think
looks cool I mean it's really difficult
because if I say something let's call
someone else would say that that's
rubbish but basically what we need to do
is we needs a kind of like infer this
underlying utility like how do I feel
about something as I change a parameter
about this object or this simulation or
this animation how do I feel about it I
mean that's quite a challenging problem
but to show you that I think it can be
done one way to do it is actually not to
present like single items to the person
but present pairwise comparisons so your
dataset doesn't become a set of inputs
and an output your dataset becomes
pairwise comparisons with which one they
preferred and from those pairwise
comparisons you can kind of there's a
law called law of comparative judgments
that you can use to try and understand
how they feel about this object so I'm
going to do it for this picture so I'm
basically just going to select which
picture I prefer yeah still like her
you can't see on that screen but there's
a little bit of blueness which is quite
nice quite like the pink face slowing
but can you see how this is kind of
converging so this is based on my
selection of what I prefer this is now
converging towards a design which is
kind of maximizing my utility and trying
to show you what that looks like behind
the scenes I purposely set this up so I
took the original image and I've changed
the contrast and I made sure it is
centered around north point five so all
I've actually done is converged back to
the original image again but you can
sort of see how I've maximized
using the expect improvement and this
Bayesian optimization routine I've
actually converged to this region which
is close to 0.5 that's kind of what as
aspecting to see
to show you on a slightly different
example this is what I refer to at the
beginning but this is like an animation
and like I said this takes a bit of time
to run and compute and I arrived at this
final design in exactly the same way so
I did pairwise comparisons of different
animations and I basically converged on
the one that I personally for look quite
cool I'm gonna give this a go because
there is a bit of time left it's a risky
Missy
so that's you know blender is a tour
which people use for 3d and
visualization and animation and it's
really cool that you just simply control
it using Python and this is running that
smoke animation when you set up this
animation it is completely pointless by
the way but it's just trying to prove a
point I think right there's a whole
bunch of parameters around the smoke
like the physics of the smoke yeah like
this density temperature difference
velocity there's like initial conditions
around and the velocity of it and things
so these are all parameters that you can
change and that influences what this
animation will look like they did it in
the same way so I use this Python
optimization algorithm I generated the
animation using blender save the outputs
and then in this case obviously it
required me as a user to interact so I
just use like a Jupiter dashboard thing
to do that and these are some of the
comparisons that you made so some of
them are like little dissatisfactory
little puffs of smoke so they definitely
didn't go through some of them like
reach the domains of the
dissimulation domain like that one so
that's not particularly pleasing so
basically doing these pairwise
comparisons I've kind of converged on
the simulation that I was quite happy
with
okay I always go faster and I'm two and
a half minutes faster than I normally am
but basically that's the end of the talk
so if anyone has any questions
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi you spoke about using engineers
domain knowledge to inform the process
did you have any look using informative
priors or did you mostly stay with
uninformative price for the Gaussian
process yeah I mean there's a whole
bunch of stuff you could do so I think
one of the reasons I kind of wanted to
show you how you can make plate the
kernel function and that mean function
is because that's one way you can embed
some sort of domain knowledge about
what's going on in the background you do
see that a lot more in like physical
bastes like domains that are using
Gaussian processes I know a machine
learning you were tend to just use zero
mean functions everywhere but actually
if you if you go to some other
conferences that are around geophysics
or anything else using Gaussian
processes there's a lot of domain
knowledge bedded into how you're
constructing it in the first place
so yeah I think I went for injecting the
human in the loop a little bit but
actually you could do a lot more up
front to make sure that's the right
approach instead I know questions
Thanks you mentioned I think halfway
through there was one iteration you
switched halfway through from
exploration to exploitation in the
algorithm how did you in terms of the
face examples and things you've tried
what kind of rules of thumb or lessons
did you learn from the different meta
rules for selecting your next point to
evaluate yes I mean yeah it's difficult
to have a one-size-fits-all and but
there is a lot of things that you can do
which are actually quite straightforward
so it all depends on how long your
simulations take and how what your total
budgets going to be if you have an idea
of what your total budget is going to be
there's actually some papers out there
which would recommend saying that you
should use your number of dimensions
times 10 as an initial sample and then
and you don't always just jump straight
in for it's better improvement what's
actually really beneficial to do first
is a few like maybe 10 times 10 sets of
just exploration and then you could just
do exploitation and you might choose
something very similar to why it's
better to improvement is achieving in
the long run but if you can afford to do
that I probably wouldn't go that's
better improvement straight away and I'd
spend a bit of time exploring a bit of
time that's boy ting kind of mix it up
do what you want I suppose but yeah it's
hard it's hard to say if in doubt use
expect improvement basically yes the
type of techniques you've demonstrated
what really prevents them from
converging on local optima that may not
be necessarily the best so for example
when you did the interactive evil loop
in the interactive evolution by
aesthetic selection that's one way of
describing it how do you know that if
you were to start again afresh you would
converge on the same picture I don't
know for that for that particular
aesthetics type problem I don't know
because I've only just started looking
at it and I
the the noise of someone saying they
like something and then asking them
again and then them changing their mind
is gonna make this quite difficult to
convert probably but in like the general
setting if you if you're using
interpolation you've got no noise then
expected improvement in theory is
guaranteed to converge because we're in
the areas that you have no data there's
always going to be a probability of
improving in the area because you've got
some uncertainty if you have noise
that's when it starts getting a bit more
complicated if you've got a stochastic
function that becomes even more
complicated so there's like layers of
complexity I think in the kind of human
and the loop
I don't know how trustworthy humans are
but I'd like to get them involved but
maybe get rid of them again one day I'm
not sure I don't know I'm sorry
hey how do you go about selecting
parameters for your kernels how do I do
it oh I take the lazy approach usually
and just go for like a squared
exponential kernel function but the
parameters another kernel oh the
parameters oh okay yeah so I just do ya
log likelihood normal and optimize over
that to get the high parameters but if I
was going beyond that like because all
these are quite straightforward problems
like samples samples so I wouldn't
necessarily do that you can do a full
Bayesian treatment of it if you want you
know if you if you if you use a library
like GP flow
that's what I'd recommend then just yeah
you can do whatever you want variation
with prints all sorts of stuff say but
in this as I'm port is just yeah
straight forwards and it wasn't even a
global Optima it was an optimizer it was
a multi start local optimizer I used to
tune it see with the duct you were doing
the optimization on in choice of
features you were using for the trade
space where you can see we optimizing
for a static case or you're also trying
to think about how the duct when it's
being used by the drone to move through
the areas going to
adding a drag or weight pencil thing
yeah so I guess the drone problem
there's well to be honest it's not just
the drawing problem it's any problem
there's a lots of other disciplines that
you would probably want to involve so
you know I was talking about adding that
component increasing the weight and I
was trying to counteract the increase of
the weight but I haven't actually worked
out how much it would weigh because I
haven't worked out what the structure
would be what materials it would be all
sorts of stuff so that parameterization
was very specific for a particular
flight flight regime and it was because
it was for a surveying vehicle it
basically had a certain flight
requirement to be rising at a certain
velocity and coming down at a certain
velocity so I didn't really take into
account all the idea of crosswinds and
the structure and the way and all sorts
Peart I mean it's a really valid point
that any problem like this is very
multidisciplinary and there's lots of
stuff to sort of think about but that
parameterization was just purely to try
and optimize over that flight that
flight regime does that answer the
question
I shouldn't finish so early I should
have dragged it out
hi just a question regarding the safety
so because currently you use a star
package do you see do you see moving
forward that data science could be
complementary if you want to safety
especially when you have cases like
vertical modelling where you could
always apply that do you smoke testing
or when you're gonna have a porous
surface modeling again we're gonna talk
about particles in terms of libraries in
terms of do I see machine learning being
used in simulation in general in yes in
competition to dynamic simulation are
complementing that yeah in fact there's
a guy that we work with who had a
master's project which was using neural
networks for help enhance kind of light
and there's a whole bunch of stuff like
compressor sensing is really popular at
the moment than that sort of domain so I
think there's a whole load of stuff that
you can do to learn like I yeah I guess
in one way you can think about this is
it took me four hours to run every
simulation
and I was kind of fitting a model to the
outputs of those separate simulations
but I could have an enhanced simulation
which has some machine learning inside
which returns me a result in a few
minutes right so yeah you could apply it
to the simulation side as well I don't
know much about it though unfortunately
okay thank you all for attending and
thanks gee
[Applause]